une allocution tardive dans le but
d'apaiser les tensions dans le pays
alors que la somalie connaît depuis
plusieurs jours des affrontements
violents
sur fond de crise politique mohamed
abdullahi mohamed a tenu à s'exprimer le
plus rapidement possible à une heure du
matin heure locale
celui qu'on surnomme pharma jo a annoncé
dans les médias somaliens vouloir
s'exprimer devant le parlement afin
d'organiser la prochaine élection
présidentielle
en tant que président chargé de faire
respecter la constitution
j'ai décidé de me présenter devant les
membres de la chambre des peuples du
parlement fédéral ce samedi et ce afin
d'obtenir leur approbation pour le
processus électoral dont ont convenu le
gouvernement fédéral les chefs des états
membres fédéraux et le gouverneur de
l'administration régionale de banadir le
discours de pharma jeu se veut donc
apaisant mais aussi à charge contre
l'opposition selon le président somalien
il a toujours été question d'organiser
des élections présidentielle et
législatives pacifiques
comme nous l'avons dit à maintes
reprises nous avons toujours été prêts à
mettre en oeuvre des élections rapides
et pacifique dans le pays mais
malheureusement nos efforts ont été
entravés par des individus et des
entités étrangères qui n'ont d'autre but
que de déstabiliser le pays et de le
ramener à l'ère de la division et de la
destruction afin de créer un vide
constitutionnel
une initiative qui survient alors que le
pays semblait retourné peu à peu vers le
chaos à mogadiscio la capitale les
habitants dû faire face à la violence
des affrontements
g fit le quartier de sigale et à cause
des combats et des bombardements d
hommes armés vêtus d'uniformes
militaires sont venus nous voir dans la
nuit et nous ont dit de partir de nous
enfuir avec nos femmes et nos enfants
malgré les mesures favorisant un retour
au calme le mandat de forme a joué tout
de même entâché de trois décès survenu
le week-end dernier
des faits qui assombrit son bilan et qui
ne devrait pas l'aider dans sa probable
candidature à une réélection